beginning of kimmy
starter roles so when you first start
learning to do aikido
taking the kimmy can be a great
challenge especially the forward role is
a huge obstacle for most people to
overcome
so there's a thing i like to practice
called the starter roll which is the
modified version of a regular roll which
makes it a little
easier for you to take the fall one of
my favorite starter rolls is the push
off roll
the push-up roll starts from a says up
i'm going to put one arm straight out
and rest my shoulder on the mat as i
rest this shoulder my head is going to
look away
now notice when i'm doing this my head's
not touching the mat at all
and as i go through my role my head will
never touch the mat this is an important
part to be emphasized
because you never want your head to
touch the ground when you're rolling
once i'm in that position i'm going to
get my feet underneath me
and push my hips straight up notice my
head still not touching
then my hips are going to come over and
i'm going to take the roll
so again one arm's going to go out i'm
going to look away from that arm i'm
looking back
my head's not touching the mat i get my
feet underneath
and push my hips straight up
and over what's nice about this push off
starter roll
is there's actually no fall in it at all
you can control the whole entire thing
so that way
if there's anything scary about falling
to you it's a nice way to ease into it
a problem with the push-up roll is it
does require some core strength and
flexibility so if your body type's not
allowing for that this might be a
difficult starter rule for you
but give it a try and see how it works
out i'm christopher hine thanks for
watching